welcome to the stream I am trying for
the first time to stream simultaneously
to both YouTube and Facebook live I
already see that the YouTube live is
working it's difficult for me to figure
out let's see if I can check out whether
Facebook live is working which would be
really cool because these streams have
only been on YouTube live and there's a
whole other audience nearly 75 80 80
something thousand people on our
Facebook page that it would be great to
be reaching so as far as I can see both
YouTube and Facebook live are currently
streaming although again it's it's hard
for me to individually confirm that so
if anybody in the youtube live can tell
me whether facebook.com slash david
pakman show is carrying the stream live
that would be really really good ok a
few things real quick if this is your
first live stream and again I guess
we're calling it a YouTube live stream
but we're at least attempting to also be
live on Facebook
number one yes we are really live unless
you're watching a replay but it is
Monday no it is Tuesday June 13 2017 at
9:01 p.m. Eastern Time if that is the
time right now then I am really live
super chat is on on YouTube so on the
YouTube stream you can use the dollar
sign at the bottom of the chat window to
send questions comments and they will be
read and it should be really sort of a
tremendous thing and
that will get started very very soon
number three new members and patrons who
sign up during the stream will get live
shoutouts and thank-yous david
pakman.com slash membership for
membership patreon.com slash david
pakman show for patreon and lastly and
importantly keep the trolling subtle
because obvious trolling will be it'll
get you banned that's basically the long
and short of it subtle trolling probably
won't so something to think about there
so I want to talk mostly about what's
going on with with Attorney General Jeff
Sessions who testified today and this is
not to Pat myself on the back because it
was sort of obvious that that this is
going to be the way that it went exactly
what I predicted yesterday is what took
place which is that on the one hand Jeff
Sessions showed up and was very
forthcoming about all assertions that
would make him and the Trump
administration look good
Oh conversations with Russians didn't
happen / I can't recall / I don't
remember conversations about how we are
going to ease sanctions or whatever
never happened wasn't involved my
recusal has been total nobody at the
Justice Department has been talking to
me but all of a sudden when the
questions start to get real from angus
King and camel Harris and so many other
people uh-oh you know it wouldn't be
appropriate for me to discuss that that
wouldn't be the right thing for me to
talk about and that we're going to have
full clips and analysis of this on the
show tomorrow but there were a few
moments that that I was particularly
struck by at one point angus King
senator angus King asked Jeff Sessions
explain why you're not answering some of
these questions and he asked Jeff
Sessions did President Trump exert
executive privilege saying you can't
talk about these particular things and
Jeff Sessions said no he did so angus
King
and asked well if he didn't exactly
exactly then why aren't you answering
the questions and jeff sessions gave
this rambling incoherent rant about how
even though Trump didn't exert executive
privilege
Jeff Sessions doesn't think it would be
appropriate to answer questions because
at some point in the future Trump might
exert executive privilege and that
should be respected and angus King who
seemed bewildered he seemed sort of like
the guy who came in halfway through not
realizing that Jeff Sessions had been
pulling this BS the entire time and and
basically said wait so why aren't you
answering the questions and Jeff
sessions went on must have been 45 or 60
seconds and it was incoherent no Trump
did not exert executive privilege but
out of respect to his right to possibly
in the future assert executive privilege
I'm now going to choose not to answer
certain questions and as angus King
pointed out completely incoherent
absolutely and completely incoherent
explanation as to why Jeff Sessions just
isn't going to answer anything he
doesn't want to answer then senator
Canella Harris from California got an
opportunity to question Jeff Sessions
and it was similarly bizarre I mean
really difficult to understand what it
was Jeff Sessions was talking about
callejero started asking Jeff sessions
about contact with Russia and Jeff
Sessions gave a complete non answer
saying I didn't have those conversations
uh well I don't recall having those
conversations although it's possible
that there might have been incidental
conversations broadly speaking about
ways in which we might improve our
relations with Russia which i think
would be a good thing wait a second you
didn't have the conversations or you
don't remember having conversations but
you might have had them or it's possible
that you had conversations which were
generally about improving relations with
Russia which it seems would sort of be
done by easing sanctions on them right
Jeff isn't that what we're figuring
out from Mike Flynn and the entire thing
so it is it is just stunning that that
these non answers and I don't recall are
were considered acceptable and the truth
is they weren't acceptable to everybody
on those panels and camel Harris
similarly to angus King going down the
same road saying okay so why aren't you
asking questions Jeff Sessions then with
camel Harris took a slightly different
approach saying something along the
lines of well as the people who
testified last week decided to do it's
sort of our policy not to answer
questions when they relate to certain
types of conversations and at that
moment I was and I you know vindicated
the writing was on the wall last week
when NSA director Mike Rogers and DNI
Director of National Intelligence dan
coates and Andrew McCabe and rod
Rosenstein they showed up last week and
did the exact same thing which was they
don't want to answer the question they
don't answer it is it classified
no did Trump exert executive privilege
to prevent the testimony no I just don't
want to testify and angus King last week
asked dan coates what's the legal basis
for your refusal to answer these
questions and Dan Coates said I don't
think I have a legal basis I told you
yesterday or maybe it was the day before
on the livestream that that is going to
be the precedent for Jeff Sessions not
answering questions and that is exactly
what he pulled with Kamala Harris where
he said it's the policy of the Justice
Department just not to answer these
questions and Camilla Harris was astute
she said well is that a policy that is
in writing is that a policy that you
discussed before coming in and Jeff
Sessions didn't really have an answer it
was like well uh you know I just I know
that it's the policy but was it
discussed well it was what is it in
writing it's it's an unspoken policy
that we didn't discuss so basically what
Jeff Sessions is saying
is I just don't want to answer questions
that could potentially make me look bad
and it was every bit as pathetic and
embarrassing as I predicted and I you
know I wish that I had been wrong and
that it was going to go a different way
and Jeff Sessions was going to show up
and appear to be appeared to be not
actually be what appeared to be
forthcoming and it was total willingness
to deny every connection that he was
asked about but all of a sudden he
doesn't remember when it comes to key
questions and all of a sudden that's not
something that I think I should be
talking about for no legal reason and
without executive privilege having being
asserted and one of the key aspects of
this that was it regularly came up and
at the time I didn't think it was a
great line of questioning because we
knew what Jeff Sessions was going to say
Jeff Sessions time and again dismissed
the assertion of former FBI director
James Comey made last week that Jeff
sessions had potentially 1/3 unreported
meeting with Russian ambassador Sergei
Kiss lyac at the Mayflower Hotel in
April of 2016
the Jeff Sessions basically said listen
there were a lot of people there and
incidentally I might have sort of shaken
hands but there was nothing took place
which could have even been
misinterpreted as an aside or a private
meeting because that would have
attracted a lot of attention and already
if you're if you're watching live on
YouTube check out the link to the
week.com
article in the description to the stream
already a picture of again it's all what
appears it appears as though in this
picture Jeff Sessions is having a
semi-private a side conversation with
Russian ambassador to the United States
Sergey slack this is a picture now okay
this is not assertions this is this is
now a picture now you could say well the
picture is a still shot and it's not a
wide-enough picture to see whether there
are people around and when
this could be considered private public
or semi-private we also because it's
just a picture we don't know how long it
lasted but again we never hear an
assertion made about Trump Russia
collusion and then discover that it's
false
there have been assertions made whose
truth we have not yet confirmed and
there's been assertions made that have
been confirmed and yet again we are now
one baby step closer already to
confirming is true something that Jeff
Sessions attempted to deny completely
during the hearing today so we're going
to get into more of the details of this
on the program tomorrow I'm going to
have video clips and in the midst of
this by the way Donald Trump's
disapproval rating has hit another new
high at 60% 60% of Americans now
disapprove of the job that President
Donald Trump is doing and this is going
to start having an impact this is going
to start having an impact on other
Republicans in terms of their
willingness to support Trump or maybe
start saying what they really feel if
you look at the Gallup daily tracking
poll that is back down to statistically
Trump's presidency low 36% he was once
at 35% but of course with a 3% margin of
error Trump effectively at his lowest
approval rating and as reported by the
hill earlier today Donald Trump's
disapproval rating now at 60% and that
will become a legislative problem for
Donald Trump the travel ban the majority
Muslim country travel ban rejected again
by now the 9th Circuit Court of Appeals
in California the Mexican wall that he
promised is nowhere on the horizon who's
talking about that bogus tax plan at
this point haven't heard a word about it
for three four or five weeks at this
point that's at a standstill
Trump's repeal and replacement of the
Affordable Care Act none of it's
happening I mean the guy is doing none
of the things that he promised and while
he still has a Republican base
Trampas base that is going to support
him indefinitely there is that this is
trouble this is problematic and I don't
know are we going to get into the low
30s are we going to see 32 or 31 I
wouldn't be surprised okay let me get to
some of the super chats if you're just
joining us please note the dollar symbol
below the chat window and you will see
that you can send super chats and those
will appear prominently and if you have
a comment or question I can take those
questions and answer them I will also
mention before I jump into that number
one if you are so kind and generous as
to sign up for a membership at david
pakman.com slash membership during the
stream excuse me getting emotional about
membership I will do live shoutouts and
thank-yous and sing your praises to
everybody who signs up for membership
live during the stream you can if you
want
on the second signup page after hitting
the red signup button you'll be taken to
page 2 of the signup process you can get
a 40% discount by using the coupon code
I voted 17 thank-yous upcoming please do
sign up this is how we're funded okay
we're mostly funded by people like you
it's not random people that we never see
or hear about it's people like you
watching the stream right now that fund
our show also you can make a pledge of
as little as one dollar per month even a
dollar a month helps at patreon.com
slash david pakman show we are trying to
get to 2,000 patrons already over 1,500
I will also do live shoutouts and
thank-yous to everybody who makes a
pledge at patreon.com slash david pakman
show so let's get to the Super chats
floppy kid has sent a five Canadian
dollar super chat what are your thoughts
on Jay Kennedy the third too young or is
he the kind of energetic leadership
Democrats need to carry a message also
has the Kennedy
Jeane sort of two thoughts on that on
the one hand you're talking about a
serious and and successful political
dynasty in the Kennedys at the same time
I think we're seeing sort of more
antipathy towards family political
dynasties than we've seen for some time
so more Kennedys I don't know could
could be interesting it's something that
remains to be seen
gr has sent a ten US dollar super chat
gr of course as I will be announcing
soon has sponsored six memberships that
we will be announcing a little contest
for upcoming gr sending a message saying
DZ thirty days be farther back in
history they bout to let me see email
coming back to me but doubt it bout to
help us D sessions for life best
interview for footlocker I ever watched
on TV and unfortunately as is often the
case with G R's super chats I don't know
what on earth you're talking about gr
but I do appreciate the contribution and
he has been a longtime supporter via
super chat of the David Pakman show
and lastly David parks has sent a $2
super chat and no comment or question
thank you thank you very much okay let
me dig into a couple of other things
that we're going to be talking about
tomorrow so as I mentioned the Jeff
Sessions testimony absolute and total
embarrassment we'll be talking about
that on the program tomorrow we will
have clips of angus King leaving Jeff
Sessions incoherently ranting and unable
to explain simple concepts senator
Connell Harris who asked Jeff Sessions
questions that again he was unwilling to
answer and then gave a completely
incoherent explanation as to why he was
unwilling to answer those questions
Trump disapproval has hit 60 percent a
record for the trump presidency we also
have yet
again I know it's going to sound like
Groundhog's Day because this is a story
that we do over and over and over again
but there are now five men who own as
much wealth as half the world's
population and you can talk about wealth
inequality from a moral perspective but
I actually don't think that that's the
best way to get the broadest possible
appeal when we're talking about wealth
inequality wealth inequality is
economically a disaster and now we have
five men one of the one of whom is of
course Facebook founder Mark Zuckerberg
who owned as much wealth as basically
half half of the world's population and
we're going to talk about the economic
impact of that and I do have to address
what is now a widely reported story that
Donald Trump is considering firing
special prosecutor in the Trump Russia
scandal Robert Muller and I know that
the initial reaction from all is wait a
second wait a second he couldn't
possibly get away with that there is no
way that Donald Trump could get away
with that right I don't know about that
I don't know about that I'm going to be
addressing that tomorrow and and sort of
in the context of everything that's
going on although congressman Adam
Schiff has tried to he's the ranking
member on the House Intelligence panel
investigating Trump Russia which is a
completely ridiculous investigation that
has been disgraced at this point Adam
Schiff has replied if the president
fires Bob Muller Congress would
immediately re-establish independent
Cowes Council and appoint robert muller
again don't waste our time and tomorrow
on the show we will discuss is that
possible is that something that they
would actually be able to do i also want
to talk about nuclear energy nuclear
energy is something that actually much
of our even program it idli progressive
audience is split on there are those who
say no nuclear energy we should be
moving off of fossil fuels and
completely to renewable clean
alternative forms of energy there are
some progressives however who say
actually we should be pushing nuclear
energy because despite the things that
could happen with nuclear energy in
terms of when things go wrong nuclear
energy is actually very very safe and it
makes sense for progressives to push for
getting off of fossil fuels getting on
nuclear while we develop alternative
energy and what I'm going to talk about
tomorrow if we have time for it on the
show because there's a lot of news and
at 4:55 a.m. this morning more news
could break if you're going to be
watching Twitter at that time I don't
know that we need the nuclear energy
so I think that it's actually a moot
debate among the left on nuclear energy
going to be talking about that and many
many other things okay so all of that
uncommon upcoming on tomorrow's program
now I've only previewed for you the
broadcast show the broadcast show is an
hour a day and we take that hour and we
chop it up into three to eight minute
clips and we publish them publish them
to the YouTube channel every 90 minutes
that's how you might be used to watching
the clips of the show you can get that
full hour by roughly 4:00 p.m. Eastern
Time every day instead of waiting for
individual clips to publish if you
become if you become a david pakman show
member at david pakman.com slash
membership we also do an entire
additional show called the bonus show
every single day there's the regular
show we do that with peace and love
fantastic but then there is an extra
show called the bonus show which is
available to all members it's more
laid-back we do more behind the scenes
stories more tech and medical stories
it's it's tremendous it's really the
best bonus show that I could imagine
okay so that is something that is
available to you if you so choose by
signing up at david pakman.com slash
membership and there is a coupon code if
you want to discount that code is I
voted 17 let's get back into the Super
chats Frank macwrite has sent a $20
super chat we
new sessions would say no collusion
can't trust him like we can't trust
Vladimir Putin it feels like nothing
moved today forwards or backwards am I
missing something surely there is Russia
collusion outside of hacking yes you are
completely right Frank that nothing has
moved forward as a result of the Jeff
Sessions testimony what is going to be
the result of this testimony well Jeff
Sessions very willing to be forthcoming
when it comes to ways in which he can
deny collusion or coordination with
Russia didn't talk to this person didn't
talk to that person wasn't briefed
briefed about this wasn't briefed about
that at the same time he refused to
answer the types of questions that might
actually have illuminated more about
what it seems only Democrats care about
finding out so nothing moved forward
Trump will say I presume that Jeff
sessions did great Jeff Sessions and
other Trump associates will say Jeff
Sessions showed up he answered questions
blah blah blah blah blah and then
Democrats will point only to Jeff
Sessions not being willing to answer
certain questions so Frank you are
completely correct just nothing moved
forward or backwards but there is now
something else to talk about if you are
the White House and someone to point to
Getti Germany have sent the two euro
super chat saying do not forget mr. Cobb
feffy coffe Fe Act coffe Fe Act ok I'm
not exactly sure what that means but
it's interesting say the least
Hobbiton has sent a five British pound
super chat as someone whose first
language is Spanish does it annoy you
that trumps English is so much worse
than yours not only that he's been
speaking English for decades longer than
I have and you know that's a compliment
I'll take I do believe that my English
is better than Donald Trump's thank you
very much
Creighton Drescher has sent a $5 super
chat asking whether John McCain is going
senile or dementia is setting in I don't
know the answer to that but what I can
tell you is that Donald John McCain
sorry dementia got me thinking about
Trump John McCain's line of questioning
- former FBI director James Comey last
week was downright bizarre trying to
draw this false equivalence between the
Hillary Clinton email investigation and
the Trump Russia investigation it was
bizarre
it was truly really weird but I don't
know about senility or dementia sort of
tough to say Getty Germany sent a five
euro super chat saying not heard about
the cough Fe Act Allah put on the table
to make social media of the president
part of the president's communication
rule set that's interesting let me make
a note of that it's not something I've
read about so far but I will make a note
to check that out very very interesting
okay let me get to some thank yous
before we get too backed up on these at
patreon.com slash david pakman show I
want to tell you about two really really
great people I could sort of channel
Sean Hannity and say these are great
Americans but I don't know if they're
American and it doesn't matter because
they're supporting the david pakman show
jonathan dana has just pledged two
dollars a month at patreon.com slash
david pakman show
that's $24 per year okay is this show
worth $24 a year to you if it is
consider making a $2 a month pledge
Rowland pop a fantastic person has just
pledged two dollars per month at
patreon.com slash david pakman show if
the show is worth $12 a year to you
pledge one dollar per month at david
pakman.com I'm sorry at patreon.com
slash david pakman show that works out
to roughly point zero zero six cents
cents per video that we I'm sorry no six
of a cent excuse me I spoke incorrectly
6/10 of a cent per video that we do it's
a pretty good deal compared to what you
might be paying for cable and also a few
thank yous to new members who have
signed up while we have been chatting
here Julian McDaniel has signed up at
david pakman.com slash membership using
the coupon code
I voted 17 which saves her 40% but gets
her 100% of the member benefits Gloria
Merrill has signed up at david
pakman.com slash membership while we've
been talking Corey Vasquez Corey amazing
has signed up for a level 2 membership
without using the coupon code at all and
Charles Levine or maybe it's Levine I
don't want to pronounce it incorrectly
has also signed up at david pakman.com
slash membership thank you it really
means a lot when people sign up when we
do the streams and when we don't don't
do the streams because we are dealing
with as you may know a 66% deficit in
YouTube ad revenue it's bad it's really
bad and I always try to frame everything
as positive and going swimmingly
but the YouTube advertiser boycott is
problematic the New York Times wrote a
very good article about this about not
just the YouTube ad boycott but about
our channel specifically there is a New
York Times article about the david
pakman show by Amanda Hess called how
YouTube's shifty algorithms hurt
independent media and I would encourage
you to check that out if you have no
idea what I'm talking about
please check it out what to quote Donald
Trump you need to know what the hell is
going on
you really really do and then you can
make a decision about whether given the
circumstances you feel that it is worth
making a contribution to the show ok
let's get to a few other Super chats
here jean-sebastien has sent 210 Mexican
dollar super chats thanks very much John
Sebastian very very much appreciate that
that
is a very very much appreciated what
else can I say what do we have coming up
on the program I don't know if you saw
this because you would have if you were
a member or listened on the radio or to
the podcast or will be watching on free
speech TV tonight at 11:00 p.m. Eastern
Time today I interviewed this was such a
fantastic interview we did a two-part
interview part one was on today's
broadcast show part two on tomorrow's
show with James Underdown James
Underdown is a professional deep bunker
he's been on dr. Phil posing as a fake
psychic the whole concept of a fake
psychic and a real psychic by the way is
hilarious but skip that for now
James Underdown who I interviewed today
went on dr. Phil and said hey listen
this whole psychic thing is bogus I'm
not a psychic I'll pretend to be one and
people will fall for it and people did
he then investigated a so-called faith
healing for the Oprah Winfrey television
network on a program called I think it's
medical miracles or something like that
and I interviewed him today and it was
absolutely fascinating absolutely
fascinating the stories that he told us
and and everything that he discussed
today so that interview is going to be
going live it's about a 25 minute
interview in total that's going to be
going live on our YouTube channel in a
day or two and similar to so James Randi
another skeptic has a million-dollar
prize from the James Randi foundation if
anybody can prove in a controlled
scientific environment some supernatural
or you know paranormal ability and James
under Downs organization admittedly a
smaller organization has a similar
hundred thousand dollar prize okay and
super super interesting interview so
that's that's going on today and
tomorrow on Thursday I'm going to be
interviewing Corey Stamper and we're
going to be talking about what does it
take for words to become words in terms
of being included into dictionaries and
this
is both political it relates to the
issue of political correctness which is
something that we've also been talking
about it relates to social media so it's
sort of a weird topic but I think you're
going to enjoy it and then Monday this
is major okay Monday we are releasing a
stunning video about political
correctness and my prediction is that if
you go into it with an open mind you
will find a lot of value in this
long-form it's going to be roughly I
think 16 15 16 minutes about political
correctness in the United States in the
West really if you go into it with an
open mind I think you will find that I
am NOT dismissive of either of the two
sides on this one side being political
correctness has become oppressive and we
are having our speech stifled by
so-called political correctness the
other side being no we need to be more
active in policing how people speak and
I think that it is going to be a video
that everybody will find something they
agree with and hopefully it will discuss
the issue in a fair and full way sort of
what we're not getting when it comes to
Trump Russia investigations we're going
to be doing that on Monday and I predict
that this will be one of the more
popular long-form videos that we will
have done so that's something to look
forward to and a lot of really really
good other interviews that are going to
be coming up and I look forward to
telling you about those let me jump back
into super chat for a little bit we've
got a ten dollar super chat from GR who
says it's time bonus show or Co me flow
don't own up to we who call that
sessions testimony just a session full
of old baloney
stanky like Trump the nasty face so much
so orange he matches the prison jammies
okay okay well there I mean there's that
thanks very much for that gr I'm having
a little bit of trouble understanding it
but I think that there's definitely
definitely something there and you know
I just don't get it because when gr
sends emails they're so coherent and
even relatively concise and then I don't
know what happens when it comes to the
super chats but it starts to get very
very odd very very strange indeed okay
here's a question that I want to pose to
you because we've gotten I've been
talking a little bit more lately about
the need for Democrats and progressives
using the term sort of interchangeably
although they are not the exact same
thing the need for Democrats and
progressives to be more than just the
anti-trump wing of the political
spectrum because being the I'm not that
guy a position being in that position
rarely works didn't work for John Kerry
in 2004 should of work george w bush's
approval rating was a disaster at the
time Trump's is even worse by the way
and I've been arguing that Democrats
really need to rally around some issues
and they need to rally around them in a
way that will actually resonate not only
with progressives but also with
independence and ideally some
conservatives so talking about everybody
should have health care doesn't mean
single-payer but although that's what I
would want but everyone should have
health care and it is a patriotic duty
to provide that and it is good for
everybody for us to provide that it is a
is a failing for us not to make sure
everybody in our country has health care
the climate climate change and
environment stop talking about it as
scientific point counterpoint okay
we know what the science is if you've
not already been convinced by the
science you're not going to be right so
the left needs to stop talking about
climate change in the terms that it has
been with conservatives and make it
again a moral patriotic and economic
issue of dealing with the crisis to the
environment these are just some examples
okay so we're thinking of whether it
would make sense to
you some kind of broader piece maybe
another show segment like a regular show
segment or maybe a longer form piece
about this issue about how progressives
must have a platform what that platform
should be in what the path forward needs
to be in terms of communicating these
ideas to those on the right and in the
middle is that interesting is that
something you think we should be doing
if it is let me know let me know and
that's something we can start working on
and exploring further if you think that
we've talked about that enough I don't
know how someone could necessarily come
to that conclusion given what's going on
right right now
then tell me hey David I don't think you
need to be talking about that but I see
and I started saying this I think it was
November what was the date when the the
protests started after the election of
Donald Trump I believe him it must have
been November 12th that first Saturday I
started saying it then the energy is
great the focus and the messaging sucks
and unless the left can get the energy
together productively then a lot of this
energy is going to be wasted it is going
to be spent energy with no results and
so I think that this is a really
important thing and that that is that's
something we're absolutely going going
to be talking about more in some way
shape or form whether we do it via a
long-form piece or not I'm sort of
flexible okay if you are just joining us
this is a live stream assuming it's 936
p.m. Eastern Time on June 13 2017 you
otherwise might be watching a replay of
the live stream number two because it is
live you are able to ask questions and
make comments to me directly the
mechanism for doing so is called super
chat super chat is triggered for lack of
a better term by using the dollar sign
below the chat window super chat
questions and comments will be read
we've already had oh I don't know a
dozen or so such comments and questions
come through super chat number three if
you sign up for membership during the
stream or make a patreon pledge during
the stream which is how we fund our show
and the studio and logistics and
connectivity and staff salaries and
everything that we do you will get a
live thank you from me and I've already
issued a few and there are more coming
membership is at david pakman.com slash
membership patronage is at patreon.com
slash david pakman show now right and
please obvious trolling and hate will
get you banned the very very
professional team of moderators that we
have has been fully deputized they know
what it is that we are looking for in
terms of comments and they have been
deputized and are allowed to block
people at will and they will and some
people have already been blocked during
this stream okay so keep that in mind
and let me get back into the super chat
a little bit here then we will do some
thank-yous Winky Dink media has sent a
five US dollar super chat your pal gr is
spittin political bars like some rap
star previously scarred by Trump's
cabinet climbing out of a clown car see
is that the same thing is that also
supposed to be one of these rhyming
concepts that gr is using I genuinely
can't tell Jean Sebastian has sent
another ten Mexican dollar super chat
the third one thank you very much
appreciate it no question or comment
Alexander Bergman has sent a five US
dollar super chat I believe Trump Russia
has been overblown and that Trump is too
stupid to collude with Russia Saudi
Trump connections more promising debate
Kyl yet there's somebody called in to
the show last week saying will I debate
Kyle kolinsky about Trump Russia and I
said what is there to debate you could
you could differ as to how much energy
should be placed into these
investigations the investigations are
going on and the investigations will at
some point come to some conclusion and
we'll find out what did or didn't happen
if the investigations will happen fully
and fairly there's really nothing to
debate unless the debate is how much
time should the Left be focused
this and as I've been talking about your
your right Alexander that it might lead
to nothing it might lead to nothing and
as a result Democrats need something for
2018 and 2020 that stands alone of Trump
and here's the thing if the Trump Russia
investigation leads to a disaster for
Trump and he resigns or is impeached
you're no longer running against Trump
in 2018 or 2020 you need something other
than being against Trump if Trump Russia
falls through and there's nothing there
you still need something else because
you can't keep talking about Trump
Russia if Trump is cleared and all Trump
Associates are cleared so the no matter
what you believe about Trump Russia you
need a platform if you're on the left
and that's what I've been talking about
for a while
creighton Drescher has sent a $5 super
chat can you say hi to my daughter my
ela or maila milah to my horror saw
Trump in president's book 445th if he
gets impeached will they remove him from
all books no I don't believe so I don't
believe that he would be removed because
he still would have been president from
January 20th 2017 until until well
whatever right well I guess we'll see
Nicki neurotic at reduce meat
consumption or try to go vegan to help
the environment especially since the
government doesn't care thanks for the
show as always until Pat I said hi
please all right Nicki says hi to Pat a
good message I am NOT vegan or
vegetarian of vegetarian but I do
believe in reducing meat consumption and
I try to adhere more to a Mediterranean
type diet and yeah what else can I say
I'm mostly off of I stopped eating pork
and lamb which are two of the if you
look at how much the carbon footprint of
different meats pork and lamb are at the
very very top I've cut those out also
are basically as smart as dogs and I
know it sounds sort of silly but I
wouldn't eat a dolphin I wouldn't eat a
whale I wouldn't eat a dog all
intelligent mammals so I'm not going to
eat pigs either and also because of a
pig digestion system it's not
particularly healthy to eat pork so
anyway I've gone that far do I ever see
myself going vegan I really don't I
really don't do I see myself going
vegetarian I could do that I could
absolutely do that but I don't know that
I'm going to do it right now
all right $5 super chat from one true
name David the left is already sending
the economic messaging it's the Hillary
wing of the DNC
which prefers the corporate money model
instead okay one true name here's where
you're right and here's where you're
wrong you were right that there is a
solid economic message from the non
corporate Democrat wing of the
Democratic Party the problem is that
they are not doing a good enough job of
using language to talk about their
economic message in a way that will be
more relevant to both moderates and to
some conservatives who likely will be
disaffected by the bogus supply side
economic ideas of Republicans and I
think that that's where the economic
messaging needs to be framed more as an
issue of nationalism and patriotism
although I've been critical of those
ideologies when they are damaging if we
can use the concepts to talk more
effectively about progressive policy on
economic issues
I am absolutely all for it so you're
right in one way you're wrong in another
way gr has sent a five-dollar super chat
Winky Dink media thinks his s don't
stink but it's twice that boy ought to
think for poppin off at gr zinc I think
I actually got the rhyming of that one
somewhat correct and for that I think we
can all be very very happy okay let me
catch up on thank-yous if I fall too far
behind
then I have to do five straight minutes
of thank-yous and I don't want to do
that let's start with patreon patreon
comm slash david pakman show here is my
question to you if I told you that
two-thirds of our YouTube channels
revenue disappeared overnight because of
the YouTube advertiser boycott but that
you could make up for it and more by
making a pledge of only $1 a month or
6/10 of a penny per video that we
publish to YouTube would you would you
do it would that be valuable to you an
individual who goes by the name of quiet
menace feels that the answer is yes
because quiet menace has just pledged $1
a month at patreon.com slash David
Pakman show
Rebecca Townsend has just pledged $1 per
month at patreon.com slash david pakman
show thank you to both of you genuinely
and seriously because we are doing
everything we can to make up for this
loss revenue I have big plans to expand
the David Pakman show those plans were I
call it temporarily interrupted by the
YouTube advertiser boycott and the way
that that will just be a blip rather
than a downturn or a negative inflection
point as we might call it in the math
world is if we can replace that lost
revenue and patreon $1 at a time is one
way that we are doing it and on that
note I also need to send a big thank you
to Rebecca Townsend for signing up for a
membership while we've been talking at
david pakman.com slash membership
Rebecca opted to use the coupon code
I voted 17 which you can enter on the
second page of the signup listen this is
not brain surgery
right we've got some pretty big plans
for the show for the next 6 12 and 18
months and if we can continue to build
our financial base we're going to do it
and we are we are starting to on YouTube
get to the upper echelon of the
progressive news and politics shows our
channel for some time has been in the
top four to five percent of YouTube at
large and as you will see if you look
around on YouTube there are many many
many right-wing political talk channels
that are doing incredibly well and there
are several but not as many progressive
YouTube channels that are up in the 500
thousand subscriber range million
subscriber range 2 million subscriber
range of course the Young Turks up there
no doubt about it
we have major plans to continue the
growth but we do have to make up some of
that loss revenue so again big thank you
to Rebecca Townsend for signing up with
the 40% discount code major thank you to
David Hollins who has signed up also at
david pakman.com slash membership opting
to use the coupon code
I voted 17 and you know what people say
David should I use the coupon code or
not I mean I would like the discount but
I could afford the full price it's your
call
I'd rather have you involved at three
dollars and sixty cents a month rather
than not at all so whether it's six
dollars or three dollars or whatever get
involved at any level that is
comfortable for you we've got a couple
more super chats to get to here douglas
Whitmore has sent a super chat David do
you agree when a candidate divorces
themself from a party labeled groupings
and campaign on positive comprehensive
message they can be successfully elected
I'm having just a bit of trouble Douglas
parsing this do I agree that when a
candidate divorces themselves from party
labelled groupings and instead campaign
on positive comprehensive messages they
can be successfully elected at the local
level absolutely at the national level
we've not seen that yet so I think the
proof will be if it happens
jean-sebastien has sent a 50 Mexican
dollar super Chad why does Trump keep
saying the US has
taken advantage of by every country
while the US has been the country
exploiting the world for at least the
past 70 years very well put question
very well put question and you're trying
to apply logic to an illogical situation
this has not been a particularly what
should I call it a sense a sensible
aspect of Donald Trump's platform I
don't know I I mean you know the thing
John's fasting is Trump has no idea what
you're talking about if you went to
trump and said the US has been the one
exploiting the world for the past 70
years beyond that thing he said to Bill
O'Reilly before O'Reilly lost his job
about hey the US has killed people too
when O'Reilly said something about Putin
being a killer Trump just doesn't really
know that much about the history you're
referring to
Alexander Bern bird Bergman sent a
five-dollar super chat does the 600m
il-6 six hundred million dollar Jeff
Bezos CIA deal taint their coverage of
Assange Snowden etc also do you
subscribe to the Chomsky media
propaganda model by and large I do
subscribe to Chomsky's media propaganda
model I think that is one of the better
parts of known Chomsky's work I so I am
on board with that the III you know
you've got to follow the money and I
think that it is perfectly reasonable to
question whether coverage of Assange and
Snowden is tainted by the six hundred
million dollar be Zoe's CIA deal and no
question about it if that's not
something you're familiar with google it
it's uh it's interesting to read about
Nicki and neurotic to really enjoy
morality with Motamedi ah yes I think
you mean Motamedi with an eye on the end
well you and Pat ever consider a similar
segment in the future I found it
interesting here's what happened I'll be
totally upfront with you but happened
with morality with Motamedi and you can
google this segment if you go to if you
go to our YouTube channel and search
morality with Motamedi you will find
segments we would present a moral
dilemma and we started with basic
like the trolley problem and some simple
medical ethics versions of the trolley
problem and then we moved on to some
which would you rather x' and then we
moved on whether you would act in one
way or another in other types of
situations we sort of ran out of
concepts because there we came to a
limit where we were repeating with
different examples the same types of
moral questions would you steal bread to
feed your family etc so I'm totally up
for bringing it back Nikki but I would
need to feel that we have a lot of
material because I don't want to just do
it once and then say hey we're out of
material again Frank macwrite has sent a
very generous twenty dollar super chat I
know this would require different gear
possibly personnel and extra time but it
would be great to see you do interviews
and segments out in the field or on
location think it would be it would add
a great dynamic to the show yeah we do
it every once in awhile like around the
primaries we did it we did it on
Election Day but I agree with you that
it would be a really good thing and
we're not there yet in terms of doing it
regularly but it is something I agree
with you Frank would be a good thing to
do Adam Wilder has sent a very generous
twenty dollar super chat which can be
done with the dollar sign at the bottom
of the chat window no question or
comment thanks very much I do appreciate
that let me do another couple quick
thank-yous here because I am as often
happens during these streams falling
behind major thank you - Roland fie
kurtz Roland fie Kurt has just signed up
at david pakman.com slash membership
Roland is an independent media hero I am
comfortable telling you we have a 40%
discount off of membership available to
you if you prefer to pay less by all
means use the coupon code at david
pakman.com slash membership and I also
want to send a thank you a major thank
you to Frank macwrite of super chat Fame
who has pledged two dollars per month
two dollars per month
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
please don't think that if you can only
do $1 a month you might as well not do
anything because after all the dollar
isn't that much if only 1 out of every
10 YouTube subscribers did the dollar a
month pledge we end the problem caused
by the YouTube advertiser boycott
instantly so the dollars make a big
difference
says II Canales has sent a $10 super
chat peace be with you David peace be
with you well thank you very much says
he I appreciate that
BW 85 has sent a $10 super chat looks
like it's a two-parter please look into
and consider doing a segment on what's
been going on at Evergreen college the
divisive nosov identity politics is
causing certain segments of the left to
eat itself continued well in the
meantime while you may be put together
part two of that super chat I did get a
call about the evergreen college
situation on the show last week and I
sort of talked about it then and we just
have I mean it's it's an interesting
story but it's been a pretty busy news
week so I have not gotten to that and we
may we may get to it later in the week
on that note that does it for today's
live stream I will stream again soon
thanks to everybody who has joined me
please do consider supporting
independent media if it's valuable to
you with a dollar or two you can do that
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
really does make a difference to us